claire nous allons nous intéresser aux
liens entre les générations mais au sein
de l'entreprise c'est un point qui est
pris de plus en plus sérieusement ça
fait les relations entre les différentes
générations xy boomer peuvent poser
problème mais également on peut en tirer
profit donc pour en parler nous recevons
mohamed mansouri pardon directeur de
face fondation agir contre l'exclusion
vous organisez demain une raie du
réunion d'information sur ce thème dans
vos locaux à vos côtés marc raynaud qui
sera justement vos invités demain qui
est président de l'observatoire du
management intergénérationnel
bonsoir alors moi mais non sourit la
réunion d'information a pour thème
pourquoi aborder la question de
l'intergénérationnel en entreprise alors
selon vous c'est une question
d'actualité ou au contraire c'est parce
que on n'en parle pas assez
alors si vous voulez ce qui nous a
amenés effectivement à organiser ce
petit déjeuner d'information
ce sont plusieurs facteurs donc si vous
voulez il ya effectivement la question
du contrat de génération qui une
question d'actualité donc qui fait que
l'entreprise est obligée entre
guillemets de traiter cette question là
mais on va dire de manière
administrative qui est ce contrat de
génération alors nous ce qu'on a
souhaité avoir comme angle au travers de
ce petit déjeuner c'est au-delà
effectivement du contrat de génération
donc qui sera présenté lors de ce petit
déjeuner c'est comment l'entreprise peut
traiter
justement la thématique de
l'intergénérationnel puisque lorsque
l'entreprise va recruter un jeune va
effectivement le mettre en relation avec
un senior sait comment se fait justement
cette relation entre le jeune et puis le
senior comment se fait la transmission
des compétences du savoir faire de la
culture de l'entreprise entre le jeune
et puis les seniors donc ça accès des
questions qu'on a eue au travers des
échanges qu'on a pu avoir au travers de
notre club d'entreprises partenaires
et c'est vrai qu'on a souhaité
effectivement répondre à cette attente
au travers de l'organisation de ce petit
déjeuner alors marc raynaud je crois
pour vous l'intérêt général
n'est pas encore un sujet en soi on a
écouté de son entreprise s'est tout
récemment une fois sur trois ils nous
ont dit c'est pas un sujet et deux fois
sur trois quand nous ont dit si c'est un
sujet une fois sur deux est long a
ajouté
mais on sait pas comment s'y prendre ça
veut dire que celle qui pompe qui vous
disent par donc ce n'est pas un sujet ça
veut dire qu'elle se voile un petit peu
la face elles se rendent pas qu'on
dirait que c'est arrivé elle 10 des
jeunes on a toujours eu de nouvelle
génération toujours été regardée avec un
certain scepticisme par les anciennes et
que depuis elle nous rachetons pense que
les jeunes sont fous ils pourront jamais
assurer l'avenir du pays
donc et en plus cons à la maison des
frères et soeurs des enfants des parents
il ya rien de nouveau
comme ceux qui pensent que ce n'est pas
sujet sont quand même assez forte mais
ceux qui pensent que c'est un sujet le
pense parce que ils ont du mal à attirer
des jeunes bien une fois qu'ils ont
attiré ils ont du mal à fidéliser faut
qu'ils auront appris leur métier les
jeunes envie de vivre d'autres
expériences et puis certains justement
actuellement en fait qu'est ce qui peut
poser problème la cohabitation entre les
trois générations x y et boomer
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui peut créer
des conflits mais enfin on peut
cohabiter sans porter très bien je crois
que le potentiel pour les entreprises
c'est passé la cohabitation de la
coopération la coopération entre les
plus anciens et les plus jeunes
généralement pose peu de problèmes c'est
comme un peu entre les grands parents
les petits enfants la cohabitation plus
délicate coopération + 10 4 c'est entre
générations proches alors donc ces gens
de 35 ans qui peut se sentir un peu
bousculé par ceux de 25 et 50 qui disent
attendez on encore là pour quinze ans
donc c'est plutôt entre xy pour resituer
y ce sont les plus jeunes x c'est la
tranche du milieu on va dire 40 40 ans
et puis
les seniors le problème c'est
principalement trait xy les grecs dé
souvent mais on va pas le sujet parce
que ce sont le sujet des autres en
particulier des x ils se sentent un peu
asticotait challenge est remise en cause
dans certaines pratiques
la génération y finalement un peu du mal
à retrouver sa place dans les
entreprises actuelles c'est peut-être ça
le problème
je pense que ce qu'offrent les
entreprises ne correspond pas totalement
aux motivations des jeunes un des jeunes
ont plus envie de faire carrière dans
une entreprise toute leur carrière ils
ont envie de voir le monde jeunes ont
plus envie d'accepter des règles ils ne
comprendront pas des jeunes ont envie de
servir de trouver un véritable sens à
leur activité donc un certain moment
même s'ils sont bien payés et ils sont
développés dans leurs compétences ils
s'abandonnent pour aller faire quelque
chose qui sent plus utile pour la
planète rien il ya décalage entre ce
qu'offre beaucoup d'entreprises et des
aspirations et des idéaux des jeunes
justement on a été rencontré les
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
on leur a demandé les avantages et les
inconvénients avoir plusieurs
générations dans une même entreprise
je vous propose d'écouter leurs réponses
ça peut être intéressant surtout pour
transmission de le savoir en fin de
l'expérience des anciens second c'est
assez positif en ce sens que ça va
permettre aux anciens de ne pas se
retrouver mis au rancart trop rapidement
de passer le relais à une passe et les
connaissances et de partir en biseau
vers une retraite paisible peuvent nous
apporter l'expérience de la vie qu'ils
ont pu avoir et non en temps ça nous
redonne 2 un petit peu un petit peu de
jeunesse quand on est trop longtemps
dans une entreprise on a besoin d'une
vue extérieur et puis je pense que les
jeunes ont plein d'idées donc c'est une
bonne idée
bon je vois pas des différentes
générations je vois seulement que les
seniors ils sont toujours en retrait
c'est bien comme ça les plus jeunes
peuvent apprendre
livre avec les plus anciens par contre
je pense que ce qu'ils faudrait pas
embaucher quelqu'un selon sap et enfin
selon ce qu'il est mais pour sa
compétence c'est à dire pour moi on
n'embauche pas quelqu'un pour sa couleur
de peau pour son origine ni pour son âge
ni pour son milieu social mais c'est
parce qu'il est compétent pour le poste
à pourvoir moi même merci on voit
finalement que le regard est assez
positif sur les relations
intergénérationnelles
est ce que les entreprises de votre
réseau vous rapportent les mêmes idées
oui si vous voulez on a effectivement de
deux choses 1 2 aspects notamment au
travers du contrat de génération parce
qu'effectivement c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui est dans l'actualité donc c'est ce
qui amène les changer puis le débat on à
la fois effectivement l'emploi des
jeunes et puis on a effectivement le
maintien en emploi des seniors et c'est
vrai que le contrat de génération tel
qu'il a été conçu a pour objectif de
pouvoir développer l'emploi des jeunes
qui sont effectivement qu'ils
connaissent la du fort taux de chômage
et puis pouvoirs renforcés consolider le
maintien en emploi des seniors donc ça
c'est effectivement un dispositif qui
permet de répondre à ces deux
problématiques que peuvent rencontrer à
la fois des seniors dans le cadre du
maintien en emploi dans l'entreprise
et puis effectivement les jeunes dans le
cadre de leurs démarches de recherche
d'emploi
donc effectivement dans les échanges
qu'on peut avoir avec nos entreprises
partenaires c'est un sujet qui est
abordé comme d'autres sujets et c'est
pour ça qu'on a souhaité effectivement
pouvoir organiser ce temps d'information
se tendent échanges avec nos entreprises
partenaires mais également d'autres
entreprises du territoire puisque se
sont associés à cette petit déjeuner
donc la maison de l'emploi de la
formation et puis la maison d'entreprise
pour pouvoir vraiment mettre sur la
table un sujet et sur lesquels
effectivement les entreprises ont
pouvoir échanger discuter mais également
pouvoir leur donner une vision plus
précise de la traduction on va dire
opérationnelle du contrat de génération
sait comment moi en tant qu'entreprise
je peux mettre en place du contrat
génération et comment moi en tant
qu'entreprise je peux effectivement
pouvoir mettre en place une démarche
autour de la thématique de
l'intergénérationnel vous parlez des
exemples concrets
nous sommes allés à la rencontre d'un
duo senior junior
lydia et marie qui ont signé un contrat
de génération dans une société
versaillaise elle nous raconte la
relation qu'elle entretienne un
reportage réalisé avec jacques de
dixmude lydia travaille comme secrétaire
de direction dans une société de
restauration façade depuis maintenant
deux ans dans quelques années elle
prendra sa retraite et la relève est
déjà tout trouvé avec marie embauché le
mois dernier ensemble elles forment un
duo la junior épaulé par la senior
un exemple concret du contrat de
génération mis en place au début de
l'année
à 21 ans et sans diplôme marine a donc
signé son premier cdi et c'est pour elle
un grand soulagement stabilité du poste
fils que ça que je vois
parce que là j'ai franchement galéré en
restauration dans le sein d'an dans le
domaine
de la vente c'est beaucoup de choses de
son côté lydia reste en poste et
transmet son savoir faire et son
expérience à la nouvelle recrue tenait
que spécifiquement un rôle de
transmission
comment dire le plaisir d'apporter à une
junior méconnaissance qu'ont expérience
et puis principalement l'amour du
travail dans la globalité qui on a tout
repris enfin n'ont pas repris mépris à
la base tout le travail concernant les
facturations les devis enfin la
formulation des courriers pour inciter
ce type de collaboration
intergénérationnelle
l'état verse cependant trois ans 4000
euros par duo à toute entreprise de
moins de 300 salariés mais lydia est
persuadé que sa petite entreprise
familiale aurait eu la même démarche
sensée z c'est selon elle une question
d'évolution des liens entre générations
il ya une plus grande compréhension
disons des seniors vis-à-vis des juniors
le système n'est plus le même c'est à
dire que le seigneur ne considère pas
que l'un juniors où le junior va prendre
sa place
tel que ça pouvait se passer à mon
époque et c'est plus une transmission
c'est plus l'aide au développement de la
société
après soit un bel état d'esprit qui omet
cependant la hausse du chômage des
seniors
selon la direccte 15 autres entreprises
yvelinoise ont mis en place un contrat
de génération mohamed mansouri ces
contrats de génération ça peut améliorer
les choses selon vous c'est l'objectif
affiché c'est à la fois développer
l'emploi des jeunes
et puis effectivement consolider le
maintien en emploi des seniors donc ça
c'est l'objectif affiché
et c'est l'objectif voulu avec la mise
en place du contrat de génération
après effectivement la pratique nous
dira si l'objectif sera atteint mais en
tout cas l'ambition est plutôt je vais
dire à la hauteur aussi de 2,2 à la fois
du chômage des jeunes
et puis du chômage des seniors et puis
ce qui est important et on a d'ailleurs
vu au travers du reportage c'est cette
notion de transmission entre le jeune et
puis le senior et ça je pense
qu'effectivement c'est le coeur de
central génération tout à fait alors
marc raynaud selon vous ce contrat peut
très bien fonctionné mais seulement sous
certaines conditions
enfin c'est une très bonne idée ce
contrat de génération d'ailleurs on le
voit dans votre témoignage des anciens
sont très contents de voir que leur
savoir être ensuite tout ne sera pas
perdu va servir les jeunes sont très
contents qu'on s'occupe immédiatement
d'augmenter leurs compétences maintenant
ils sont tous dans une phase de relative
lune de miel
c'est la découverte ces deux nouveautés
on sait très bien en termes de relations
interculturelles qu'après la phase de
lune de miel une phase relative des
illusions parce que la coopération inter
générationnelle ce n'est pas naturel
la nature c'est que chaque génération se
retrouvent entre elles avec ses propres
façons de faire ses préférences donc
après la phase de lune de miel où il
vous faudra être très très attentif à ce
que la coopération s'installe dans la
durée
c'est selon vous en fait il faut
finalement
un manager qui trouve une bonne équipe
un bon duo c'est à dire un senior qui
est la capacité de transmettre parce que
tous ne sont pas capables de le faire
mais comme des émotions manssouri de la
transmission c'est le ces deux
dispositifs le plus intéressant est au
coeur de ce contrat mais tout le monde
n'est pas pédagogue né c'est pas parce
qu'on maîtrise très bien depuis 20 ans
40 ans un geste qu'on veut c'est
d'enseigner
il ya énormément de choses qu'on a
apprise qui sont maintenant enfouis
implicite de l'ordre de reflex dont on
n'est même plus complètement conscient
et qu'on veut repenser à transmettre
qu'on ne saurait pas transmettre sans
l'aide d'un pédagogue ou d'un notaire
d'un intermédiaire c'est vraiment la
responsabilité du management d'organiser
cette transmission pour préserver le
savoir-faire dans l'entreprise vous
auriez peut-être quelques clés ou en
termes de management intergénérationnel
eh bien je crois que la coopération
inter générationnelle peut apporter de
la valeur la créativité de l'innovation
dans l'entreprise si elle est organisée
ces dépôts rganisée les différences de
générations peuvent créer le l'enfer un
beaucoup de malentendus beaucoup de
conflits plutôt une baisse de
performance qu'un gain donc moi je suis
pas un chantre de la diversité en soit
la diversité bien sont celles utilisées
universités intergénérationnel pareil
donc il faut mettre les gens ensemble
pour que c'est effectivement l'occasion
de travailler ensemble mais il faut
aussi les aider à être curieux sur les
spécificités de l'autre à faire un pas
vers l'autre pour définir ensemble un
mode de fonctionnement différent d'une
mode de fonctionnement préféré de
chacune des deux parties
xom de fonctionnement partagé au
bénéfice des deux parties et seniors et
juniors limoux lézignan qui veulent
apprendre aux seniors finalement je vous
remercie en tout cas de nous avoir
rejoints sur ce plateau les 2